MaMartine, Michel et Luc, bonso.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On revoit les images de cete
grgrosse structure blanche au
cecentre-ville de Montréal que
bebeaucoup parmi vous mémé pas n
didisant que l'on va défigurer e
cecentre-ville et on voit les
imimages. Ça existera pas. C'est
teterminé. Mais le projet
rerecommence à zéro. On n'en
paparlait mais d'abord Mme Plane
etet Monsieur Legault en
coconférence de presse.
VAVALÉRIE PLANTE
mamairesse de Montréal
- - Malgré tous les efforts qui
onont été déployés, il n'en
dedemeure pas moins qu'il y a un
sesecteur qui était problématiq.
DaDans le centre-ville, on était
dadans une impasse, c'est le cas
dede le dire. Puis à la lecture
dudu rapport des experts, c'état
clclair pour moi, mais c'était
auaussi clair pour mon équipe,
quque le tronçon en aérien danse
cecentre-ville, c'était une errr
hihistorique qu'il fallait
ababsolument éviter de faire.
- - En enlevant le tronçon au
cecentre-ville, on a eu des
didiscussions avec les dirigeans
dede la Caisse de dépôt.
CÇa change beaucoup le projet
popour la Caisse de dépôt, parce
ququ'eux comptaient, pour invesr
1010 milliards, sur une
rerentabilité du projet de
l'l'Est jusqu'au centre-ville.
EnEn enlevant le bout du centre-
viville, puis en proposant,
jeje parlerai tantôt d'autres
chchangements, bien eux ne veult
papas poursuivre dans le projet,
pupuis je les comprends.
- - Je les comprends. Il a été
asassez transparent et il est dt
quque la caisse a dit que si vos
enen avez le tronçon au centre-
viville, ce projet ne tient plus
dedebout parce qu'elle n'est pas
rerentable parce que les gens vt
alaller sur la ligne verte pour
alaller au centre-ville. Moins e
kikilométrage pour la caisse. Et
auaussi moins de facilité il fat
lele dire pour les gens de l'Est
d'd'aller au centre-ville. Toure
tatable. Martine, est-ce que
c'c'était un accident qui était
prprévu depuis quelques semaine?
- - Cela faisait un moment où ln
cocommençait à discuter de trour
dedes différentes solutions. Le
gogouvernement avait mis en plae
unun comité d'experts qui est ps
vrvraiment décisionnel, qui a ps
prpris part à la décision mais
ququand même envoyée que le prot
dedevait être vu de toute façone
gogouvernement avait pas le cho.
C'C'est quand même dans le cent-
viville, les gens n'en voulaient
papas. Ça avait difficile de
foforcer un projet aussi énorme.
JeJe souligne en passant que cet
axaxe, cette tronçon aérien pase
dadans des circonscriptions
frfrancophones à quelques mois s
élélections, alors le gouvernemt
a a dit : on va vider d'abord le
prprojet. Honnêtement ils ont
gagardé leur carte sérient, I, t
prprojet Toulon de ces
didiscussions. Cela fait à peu
prprès un mois à des discussions
enen coulisses. Vous dîtes que s
gegens n'en voulaient pas de
trtransport aérien.
- - Beaucoup de gens ne voulaiet
papas de tronçon. Cela avait été
efefficace en laissera jamais,
MiMichel, vous étiez parmi ceux
ququi dans vos nationalismes
ététaient très critiques face àe
prprojet.
- - Oui il y a rien qui vaut de
dédéfigurer le boulevard René
LéLévesque sur quelques kilomèts
auau centre-ville de Montréal
apaprès ça ne met pas de bon se.
C'C'est ça qui a fait bloquer
l'l'élève de Montréal. À partire
cece moment, la quête qui avait
fafait un tracé qui dédouble la
liligne verte du métro, il faut
papas l'oublier, car la chambree
cocommerce déleste athée : pas
d'd'accès direct, un petit passe
dudu REM au métro, ce sera pas
cocompliqué.
- - Je vais revenir. Excusez-mo.
EsEst-ce que je relèvera vraimet
alaller? Les autres régions à
rerelier.
- - Mais il y a un vrai lien.
C'C'est un petit transbordement
ququi n'est pas important. Un
momoment donné, cela se fait bi.
C'C'est comme traverser à Lione-
GrGroulx. Marché sur lequel vous
êêtes rendu. C'est pas plus
cocompliqué que cela.
- - Luc?
- - Cela fait longtemps que je
n'n'ai pas vu un gouvernement
chchanger son fusil d'épaule
avavec... il s'est obstiné maisa
tetenté des s choses. La dernièe
momouture qui était proposée por
ReRené Lévesque et c'était
exextraordinairement ambitieux.
C'C'était la moitié des voies de
cicirculation et je me réjouisss
dede cela. Mais quand même. C'et
énénorme. Ensuite il y avait cee
esespèce d'esplanade qui a été
écécrit, il y avait de larges
trtrottoirs et ils ont été pour
esessayer de faire passer le
prprojet. Bravo. Ça n'a pas suf.
CoComme ça ne suffisait pas, la
sosolution était de dire que l'n
vava brancher le REM sur la lige
veverte. Michel a raison. L'un s
prprincipaux défauts de ce projt
ététait qu'il était en parallèle
avavec la ligne verte appartenat
hohonorer vos grands jusqu'au
cecentre-ville. À métro coûte 1
mimilliard de dollars.
- - On les voit.
SiSi le projet se rend et
dodonnerait mon client, il y aua
unun crochet à faire et les gens
popourront aller au centre-vill.
LaLa prétention de la caisse étt
dede dire : avec les gens que ça
atattirés, il fallait sur 20 an,
lala ligne verte était et allait
êêtre saturée de toute façon.
MaMais bon.
- - C'est une bonne question pae
quque pour la ligne verte ne sot
papas saturé, il faudrait rajour
l'l'être. Rajouter des traits, t
unun gros coup. C'est un coup qi
sese compte en milliards de
dodollars. Au moins 1 milliard.
DoDonc, ce n'est pas rien de die
quque l'on va connecter sur la
liligne verte. Cela prend plus e
wawagons. Il y a aussi la questn
dede fréquence. On va arriver àa
frfréquence maximale. On n'est s
àà la fréquence maximale même à
trtrois minutes. On va s'y rende
enen ajoutant des trépas
- - Sur les terres politiques,
MaMartine vous l'avait dit, on t
àà l'approche d'une campagne
élélectorale, la mairesse n'état
papas confortable avec la portin
cecentre-ville. Elle n'était pas
coconfortable avec la place qu'n
lului avait donnée autour de la
tatable à CDPQ. Mais cela
coconcédait que la mairesse lève
papas, des gens les valaient pa,
cecela coûte une fortune, on
ararrête tout cela. C'est plus
fafacile de arrêté le trait
mamaintenant.
- - En fait, il a passé le messe
chchrétien à avoir REM de l'Est.
IlIl y a Pointe-aux-Trembles, il
veveut avoir quelque chose pour
leles gens déleste. Il va devoir
trtrouver une solution pour le
trtronçon Notre-Dame pour se
rerendre complètement dans les
ststeppes. Il y a quand même des
coconséquences à cette décision
auaujourd'hui parce que c'est ue
grgrosse nouvelle. C'est un prot
dede 10 milliards de dollars. Iy
a a pas beaucoup de réponses qui
onont été données aux conséquens
dede son geste aujourd'hui.
D'D'abord, il va y avoir
dédécompensation que le
gogouvernement devra verser à la
cacaisse de dépôt et cela ne s't
papas mouillé là-dessus. Ça rise
d'd'arriver après les élections.
NoNotre affaire, on efface et on
rerecommence. Un nouveau projet.
OnOn devait le livrer en 2029 et
plplus de projet. C'est la
réréalité. C'était 10 milliardse
dodollars. Est-ce que un jour ce
prprojet va voirir le jour?
- - Vous hacher la tête Michel t
ququand Marc Kennedy qu'elle
rerecommence à zéro. Mais je vos
sosoumets que l'expertise de CP,
onon peut les trouver intenses,
mamais ils ont développé une
exexpertise énorme. Le ministèèe
dedes transports et la ville de
MoMontréal et la STM qui va être
mmêlée à tout cela.
VoVous y croyez Michel pour vrai
unun projetde l'est dans le
cecentre-ville?
- - C'est quatre groupes ont
bebeaucoup plus d'expertise quea
cacaisse des dépôts.
CeCe sont de vrais joueurs à
MoMontréal. C'est le Santander
rarapidement et le peuvent ça va
sese faire. Ce n'est pas complié
dede voir ce qui a été fait
jujusqu'à maintenant parce qu'il
vava y avoir des plans de la
Caisse des dépôts et faire la
leles adapter. Après c'est de
vovouloir politique et mettre de
l'l'argent.
- - Luc êtes-vous optimiste?
- - Je précise. Donc,
prpremièrement, c'est un projet
BOBOO, ça veut dire que les
fifinances locales. La STM est
cacapable d'opérer une ligne de
mémétro ou de transport aérien
sasans aucun problème. Elle est
cacapable de construire et en ft
dédémonstratio de gros garages i
cocoûtent des milliards de
dodollars. Elle est capable de e
fafaire. La différence c'est le
fifinancement. La STM a jamais
fifinancé un projet. La caisse
ararrivait avec des milliards et
tutu vas me donner 8 % pendant 0
anans. C'est le gouvernement du
QuQuébec a fait un calcul et a t
ququ'il pouvait se priver des
mimilliards de la caisse. Et cea
vava marcher et va coûter moins
chcher que 8 %. Une dernière
chchance que la caisse faisait
c'c'est la captation de la valer
foncière c'est lorsqu'on
coconstruit proche des gares eta
cacaisse va chercher...
unune partie de la valeur
fofoncière.
- - Je repose la question. La
chchambre de commerce de l'Est i
sese désole. Est-ce qu'on va vo,
c'c'était 2029 le projet. Peut-
êêtre pas 2029 mais c'étaient
l'l'objectif. Mais est-ce qu'ona
avavoir décidé de mêler 30 ou 3,
jeje sais pas, projet réalisé pr
rerelier la seule région qui
n'n'allait pas actuellement vers
lele centre-ville, l,est?
- - Parlons de l'amiable. J'ai
papassé ma vie active à entendre
paparler de la ligne bleue qui
n'n'est pas faite. Le troisièmet
a a été repoussé d'un an. Et là,
onon arrive avec ce projet. Je
susuis moins optimiste que Michl
mamais effectivement c'est le
sosommet au travail et qu'ils
ararrivent avec unun travail est
bibien ficelé, rapidement, au
bubureau du premier ministre
paparlait une question de mois t
papas d'année avant d'arriver ac
unun nouveau projet. Et qu'on
trtrouve le moyen de les financ.
OnOn voulait 25 % Québec et 25 %
OtOttawa et 50 % Caisse des déps
popour les REM. Il va falloir
rerefaire le montage financier.
OuOui, cela pourrait, cela risqe
d'd'être tout comme les travaux
dedes retards.
- - Il y aura du retard, Michel,
ilils vont entrer sur la ligne
veverte et merci bonsoir.
- - Et les partait pas de zéro.t
leles partenaires choses qui ont
dédéjà été faits et pour le res,
lala STM et c'est comment faire
popour les problèmes c'est qu'oa
lele syndrome de la ligne bleue.
ElElle a été promise cinq fois t
quque le gouvernement n'a pas
vovoulu donner son financement.
C'C'est ça la raison pour laquee
çaça n'a pas marché. Si il y a a
vovolonté politique du
gogouvernement de financer,
MoMonsieur Legault a été clair
auaujourd'hui, cela va se faire.
C'C'est le fond comme indéniabl,
onon va tomber...
- - est-ce que c'était un manque
dede notre part, je parle
cocollectivement, d'imagination
d'd'avoir quelque chose qui aurt
pupu marcher avec une structure
susurélevée sur le René-Lévesqu?
LeLeque?
- - Pas impossible que ce soit n
mamanque d'imagination. Peut-ête
ququ'une fois construite en arrt
didit que c'est pas si grave et
papas si mal. C'est pas
imimpossible. Mais il y avait ps
quque cela. Il y avait le
fifinancement. C'était trop che.
PrPremièrement c'était trop che,
popour cent pendant 100 ans,
c'c'était trop cher. Deuxièmeme,
cece chevauchement avec la ligne
veverte, cela faisait pas de se.
OnOn peut pas avoir un métro qui
cocoûte 1 milliard et à côté REM
rorouler à côté de l'autre pendt
plplusieurs kilomètres. Ça faist
papas de sens.
- - Bon. Alors, on va suivre ce.
JeJe sais pas si je serai toujos
llà quand on va annoncer
coconcrètement ce projet. Mais
didisons...
- - Patrice? Si je peux me
pepermettre. En théorie, ça
dedevrait aller plus vite que le
prprojet de CDPQ, parce que pase
brbranche centre-ville. En
ththéorie, ça peut aller plus ve
d'd'accord en théorie.
- - D'accord. En théorie.
VoVous êtes résolument optimiste
MiMichel. J'ai trop d'exemples,
l'l'avoir réservé Lépinay fait,l
y y a des affaires qui
n'n'arrivaient jamais qui devait
ararriver. Maiais bon. La caiss.
jeje crois qu'elles ont dévelopé
unune expertise malgré tout est
nonormale. Et vous êtes pas
d'd'accord Michel.
CoCombien il reste de temps?
- - À chaque nouveau gouvernemet
ilil y avait quelqu'un qui ajoue
ququelque chose pour Pix-IX, et.
C'C'est pour ça que ça se fait
jajamais.
- - On parlait de développer ves
lala vallée.
- - Le premier ministre va
bebeaucoup aimer ça.
- - C'est là où la chicane va
popogner. Montréal voudra que ça
leles cervelles écartées plus
hohonorées. Le gouvernement va
vovouloir que ça traverse pour
alaller à Laval et ce sont des
teterres agricoles. Il faut faie
trtrès attention au type de
dédéveloppement que l'on va fai.
- - Belle réunion en vue. Merc